vamos a hablar de la última
actualización en torno a la red social
'twitter' porque los accionistas de esta
compañía votaron casi por unanimidad la
aprobación del acuerdo de compra
alcanzado con él en moscú a principios
de este año recordemos como se acordó
entonces originalmente la compra de la
compañía valorada actualmente en 32 mil
millones horas aproximadamente por 44
mil millones de dólares en el mes de
abril luego el fundador de tesla se
retiró de este acuerdo en el mes de
julio alegando que tú te había
incumplido su uso condiciones también
pues todo lo que tiene que ver con las
cuentas falsas de esta compañía sobre
todo que no le mostraron la información
que él quería ver abrimos así 1 capítulo
de esta novela y por supuesto nos
acompaña una de las seguidoras más ferré
de todo esta polémica entre twitter y lo
hemos daniel hablando de nuestra
creencia de economía o la raúl muy
buenos días llevamos días sin hablar de
twitter y yo ya estaba preocupándome
pero bueno aquí estamos y creo que vamos
a seguir hablando dani porque esta
noticia pues tiene muchísimo desarrollo
salud entonces también stefan si de
tetera y consultor de transformación
digital sea mil gracias por su tiempo
por estar nuevamente con nosotros en
directo américa de frankfurt y 4 buena
mañana
hola raúl buenos días para ti y para
todos cómo nos va
samir muy bien pues primero comencemos
con una actualización sabemos que hay un
juicio ahora en octubre los accionistas
de twitter ya votaron a favor de que se
llevara a cabo el acuerdo en que va toda
esta novela
si son dos procesos diferentes el
primero y la noticia de esta semana
tiene que ver con un proceso digamos
formal que se tiene que cumplir de parte
de la junta directiva de twitter al
llevarle a los accionistas su
recomendación de aceptar la propuesta
que había hecho y las moscas a comienzos
del año entonces se cumple ese otro hito
la la asamblea digamos general de
accionistas de la compañía aprueban el
proceso pero mientras tanto como decían
ustedes ahorita venimos viendo un
proceso en el cual no se retractó o por
lo menos ha tratado de retractarse la
junta directiva le ha dicho a mosca
usted nos pasó una propuesta nosotros le
entregamos la información y esto es como
dicen en eeuu y en inglés binding quiere
decir que usted no se puede sacar tan
fácil y sencillamente es la razón por la
cual están yendo a juicio a finales de
este mes o comienzos del próximo mes
summer que podría pasar en este juicio
realmente y lo hemos estaría entonces
obligado a comprar esta empresa o qué
sanciones digamos incurriría cuando pues
digamos que finalmente él diga pues
igualmente no la quiero comprar cuánto
dinero al mejor podría pagar de qué
estamos hablando en ese caso
históricamente este tipo de procesos se
han inclinado hacia la compañía que es
objeto de adquisición es decir en
procesos similares históricamente en los
jueces han dicho no usted había puesto
en la mesa una propuesta usted tiene que
cumplir o si no tendrá que pagar algunas
algunas multas que está haciendo más que
está utilizando básicamente tres
conceptos el primero no me dieron la
información completa el segundo creo que
hay demasiados votos que no son usuarios
reales y que por ende los números que me
entregaron son
son y están inflados son falsos y el
tercero una noticia que vimos la semana
pasada ya comienzos de esta semana
cuando el ex jefe de seguridad de la
compañía básicamente salió a testificar
ya decir que la seguridad la compañía
era prácticamente inexistente no sabemos
cuánto pueden ser las multas en el
contrato original había una cláusula de
mil millones de dólares pero creemos que
dado digamos lo que ha pasado y cómo ha
avanzado el proceso el monto para que
moscú no tenga que comprar pero si tenga
que compensar de alguna manera la
compañía será mayor que ese monto samir
aquí lo clave es precisamente si lo
conozco puedo demostrar que no se están
dando las condiciones el paga sus mil
millones de dólares y se sale del
negocio que es lo que él quiere hacer y
que tanto puede ayudarle todo esto que
pasó porque quiero profundizar en el
tema del ex jefe de seguridad de twitter
que dice que inclusive china podría
estar recopilando datos de los usuarios
violando así pues normas de seguridad
que tanto puede ayudarle eso sí nos
puede profundizar en qué fue lo que dijo
este ex jefe de seguridad
si al final lo que estamos viendo es un
empleado peter sad con una persona muy
renombrada en el mundo digamos de la
seguridad que fue contratada en el 2020
por la compañía como jefe de seguridad y
que básicamente lo que lo que está
diciendo es óigame ya no existe
seguridad todos los ingenieros de la
compañía la mitad de los empleados de la
compañía tienen acceso a lo que usted
pone en sus cuentas a la información
incluso usted tiene guardada y que no ha
compartido públicamente y esta
información se está vendiendo en el
mercado negro este es un personaje que
además negoció con twitter una salida
por 7 millones de dólares un bono que le
dieron a comienzos del año utilicemos
que ese pago extemporáneo al ejecutivo
constituye una falla en el proceso
digamos de lo que venían hablando en el
proceso de negociación entonces digamos
que muestra venido llenando de
argumentos cada vez más para tratar de
salirse del proceso no sé hasta dónde y
las revelaciones de seguridad puedan
llevar a que nos tenga más razón porque
al final del día moscú formación nos
hizo una oferta basada en esa
información no pareciera que aquí hay
nada diferente aunque claramente cada
vez que alguien menciona china pues en
eeuu tiemblan lo ven como el coco y
entonces tiemblan y dicen nuestros iba a
ser gravísimo claro y precisamente eso
quería hablar samir porque recordemos
que hemos también es dueño del 10 por
ciento de las acciones de esta compañía
seguramente también estaba bien empapado
lo que estaba ocurriendo dentro de
twitter entonces porque ahora digamos
que hay tanta traba y tanto requisito
para que él realmente pueda adquirir la
compañía bajo sus condiciones o sea esto
hace pensar que si realmente él desde un
principio si quiso comprar esta compañía
o no o como lo ves
yo creo que hay dos cosas que son
importantes redimensionó una y es que es
muy posible que esto haya salido como
una especie de broma o una reacción
impulsiva a un tuit que puso en su
momento y alguien dijo oiga y porque más
bien no compra twitter no y las semanas
siguientes vimos que había comprado el 9
por ciento y a la semana siguiente le
ofrecieron un puesto en la junta dijo no
no quiero el puesto la junta sabe que
más bien voy a comprar toda la compañía
listos pero lo otro que ha pasado y hay
que tener en cuenta lo que ha pasado en
los mercados es que la compañía en ese
momento tenía una capitalización de
mercado mucho mayor a la que tenemos hoy
hoy estamos hablando de una
capitalización de mercado casi de 20 por
ciento menos y eso que ha subido en los
últimos días pero estamos hablando de
que el precio de acción hoy amanece a 41
con 90 cuando él ofreció 54 con 20
entonces la posible financiación que
había negociado que además impactó
digamos el precio de acción de tesla
porque muchos de los inversionistas de
tesla dijeron oiga van a usar estas
acciones como la como colateral para la
compra de twitter modelo de negocio que
todavía mucha gente no entiende cómo se
puede monetizar y lo llevó a decir oiga
espere de pronto no puedo seguir pagando
los 54 con 20 y lo más importante es que
la oferta que él hizo no es una oferta
para comprar a precio de mercado sino es
una oferta para comprar a un precio
específico que hoy para los
inversionistas de 'twitter' sería una
gran venta